In this tutorial, we'll explain how to integrate your CI-CD platform with BurpSuite's Enterprise Edition.
We're going to demo setting up Jenkins, but the steps are essentially the same for other platforms.
We have plugins for other CI-CD systems and also a generic plugin that can easily be used with any platform.
The first thing we need to do is to set up an API user in BurpSuite Enterprise Edition.
So we're going to log in as admin and then go to Team and Add New User.
We enter the details of the user and we select the option to use an API key.
We also need to add the user to the Scan Initiators group so that they can trigger a scan.
Then we save the user and we copy the API link.
You need to keep a note of the API link and I'll paste it into a new browser tab.
You then need to download the BurpSuite plugin for Jenkins from our website.
Then you log into Jenkins as an admin user.
Go to Manage Jenkins, then Manage Plugins, and then the Advanced tab.
Under Upload Plugin, click Choose File and select the HPI file from within the zip file that you downloaded.
And click Upload.
The plugin will be installed and you need to check the box to restart Jenkins when the installation is complete.
After Jenkins restarts, sign in again.
Then create a new item, give the item a name and select the type of project that you want to use.
In the Build section, add an Execute Shell build step.
In the Execute Shell build script, write a short script that echoes the URL of the running application that you want to scan.
This would typically be in a staging environment and will already have been deployed by a previous step in your build pipeline.
The URL needs to be echoed assigned to BurpScan URL.
Then add a BurpScan build step.
You need to provide the URL of the Burp API.
This should be the URL that you copied earlier, less the version suffix.
This is all you need to do to get a default scan running from your CI pipeline.
But you'll often want to configure some custom settings for the scan.
You can use the in-browser API interface to create suitable settings.
You get to this by browsing to the API URL that we copied earlier.
In the REST API definition, click on Scan.
We've already set this one up.
You can define the site URL and name.
You can select a named scan configuration.
And we've selected light active checks.
At the bottom, the interface shows you a curl command.
You can use this to trigger the defined scan via the REST API from any tool.
For CI integration, we just need to copy the JSON that defines the scan settings.
You then go back to Jenkins and paste this into the scan definition box.
You can also configure the issue severity and confidence levels that will cause the build to fail.
So we could specify that we only want to fail the build when a high severity issue is found.
If we go back to Burp Suite Enterprise Edition and look at the sites, we can see that in this installation, we have two folders containing some sites that were already set up.
If we go to Jenkins, we can trigger a build manually by clicking Build Now.
Obviously, in the real world, the build will be triggered by a commit or a pull request or on a schedule or some other event.
Once a build is running, you can look in the console output to confirm that the Burp scan is happening.
Now, in Burp Suite Enterprise Edition, if we refresh the sites page, we can see that a new site has appeared for this configured scan.
If we click into the site, we can see that the scan has been initialized.
And if we go into more details, we can see the details of the website that is being scanned and that the scan was generated by the API.
Once the scan has completed, in Jenkins, we can see in the console output any issues that have been found.
The build log includes details of the types of issues that were found, their severity and their location.
And in this case, we can see that the build has failed because some high severity issues were discovered.
If we want, we can also look in the Burp Suite Enterprise Edition UI and see the details of the same issues there.
So that's how to integrate your CI-CD platform with Burp Suite Enterprise Edition.
And that's how to integrate your CI-CD platform with Burp Suite Enterprise Edition.
And that's how to integrate your CI-CD platform with Burp Suite Enterprise Enterprise Edition.